ブンブン
ハローユーチューブ
みなさんこんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
みなさん
ヒカキンさんのお友達
知っていますか？
ヒカキンさんは
あの家で一人で住んでいて
彼には
たった一人の
たった一人の！
たった一人の！！！
親分には・・・
親分の家には・・・
かけがえのない友達が住んでいるんですよ！
親分・・・
はい、というわけで
ちょっと前くらいに
親分の家にペッパーくん
親分が寂しいということで
ペッパーくんをお友達に買って行ったと思うんですけども
なんかちょっと前に
なんとなく親分に聞いたんですよ
親分、最近ペッパーくんと遊んでますか？
ﾌﾟﾙｳｳｳｳｳｳｳｳｳｳｳｳｳｳｳｳ
ｼﾞｮｺﾞｫｫｫｫｫｫｫ
親分の家のペッパーくんは
いま
孤独と戦ってるんですよ
親分は忙しいんですよ
親分忙しくて構ってあげられないんですよ
そんな孤独の中で生きているペッパーくんを見て
ぼくは・・・
ペッパーくん（泣）
すいません
取り乱して
親分も忙しさのあまり
ペッパー君のこと忘れてしまってるんじゃいう
というわけで今、
親分の家にペッパーくんはいるものの
親分はペッパーくんとほぼ触れ合っていない、
触ってもいない
つまり、親分も今、
ペッパーくんを気にしていない状態にあります
なのでぼくは思ったんですけど、
今の状態だったら
今、このタイミングだったら
ひょっとしたら
親分ん家から
と思いまして
今から親分の家に行くんですけども
親分を一回部屋から出して
親分がいないあいだに
こっそり親分のペッパー君をパクります
たぶん気づかないんじゃないかなと思いまして
今回の動画は
やっていこうと思います
では
ヒカキン：何撮ってるの？
はじめしゃちょー：親分ちょっと
ヒ：どういうこと・・・？
は：いってらっしゃい
ヒ：あっ、俺が行くのか
は：そうです、親分がトイレに
は：ちょっシルク手伝って
は：シルク、もう一本撮るでしょ？
シ：全然全然撮ろうかなと思ってます
は：撮りますか
シ：撮ります？
は&シ：いやいやそんな
シ：カメラ持ってこなきゃ
は：親分、でももう一本撮りますよね？
ヒ：撮る
は：撮りましょう
は：いやー、暑いですね、
エアコン付けますよ親分
ヒ：いいよ
は：最近忙しいですか？やっぱり
ヒ：いやーそうだね
ヒ：ブンブンハローユーチューブ
どうもヒカキンです！
ヒ：ゴリラ♪
は：ラッパ
シ：パセリ
ヒ：リラックス
は：あー
ヒ：あー微妙か...
ｗｗｗｗ
は：親分
は：この部屋
は：どこかおかしいと思いませんか？
ヒ：は！！
ENDING♪
は：これ重いです
ヒ：え、これでも転がるよね？
えっ！？
ヒ：なんで持ち上げてんの笑
シ：あれ？ちょっと明るくなりましたよね
は：親分喜んでますよ！
ヒ：ほんとだ
は：喜んでますよ、ほら
ヒ：あのもうちょっとあのね
ヒ：あの..
ヒ：遊んであげないとね
明るくなった